ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming I would like present some
information and some a solution of my
work on institute for metal forming of
metal forming unfilled materials
characterization and using of mathematic
especially CUDA link to develop some new
solvers for nonlinear equations which I
use to explain some phenomena in
material science like diffusion
temperature field or deformation which
is mostly nonlinear it's not elastic
it's everything plastic okay first of
all where is Institute of metal forming
in Germany in near to Dresden and
Leipzig it's small city sewing I 30,000
people and 5,000 students so we are
really slow as small in according to the
another cities our Institute is have
five groups working groups teams which
one of those I'm ahead we work together
to describe materials and build new
models to describe some processes
production processes or also to generate
some models for controlling very fast
controlling controller in this case we
will concentrate on multi scaling
modeling maybe someone from you if you
read about it this is some idea which we
start from a tome scale and going on to
the something like here crashing test
and also simulation for that we need
mostly
very deep knowledge about material our
group concentrate on this field here we
leave this field to the physic and we
work together with physics and they give
us some models to describe some
phenomena like I don't know a slip
effects and so on if we go if we go to
the topic using of Mathematica as you
see we use Mathematica to describe or
also take all data together into the
some models and transfer this to the
fast control systems or industrial scale
processes we work on process and
material optimization as well as
development of new technology and new
materials those technology are must be
you must be cheap first of all and good
22 yup mint and and so on sorry okay
what we use to solve our system as we
know all for material science or
engineering construction mostly is used
f.a.m metal f.a.m which give us a very
smooth expression of of some phenomena
we use I use here finite difference
method to describe all of those
phenomena because it was simply to
implement into the GPU calculation so i
will show you everything about it so we
started first of all about said i don't
know what's sorry first of all in
Mathematica mostly function used CPU to
solve some problems we can use two
different ways to do this first of all
we can use serial processing or parallel
processing it's very simple to implement
or in function compile using compile we
can we can parallel parallel easy this
and or use another function like
parallel evaluation or parallel table
and so on we can use it and here are the
transfer transport data with with
between ram data and cpu that's mostly
the problem of some code because using
rom transferred between CPU or ram we
have large lack of time we have small
speed of data transfer sleep I don't
know sorry but
don't know what's happened mostly ideas
of collects can you get it a little bit
yeah okay can you put it a little bit
okay so we use mostly in codes of
commercial software this data transfer
from round to a video RAM on GPU and
then computed and return data and this
is large luck if we have a large data
set I think 1000 10000 or something like
that it's the boundary of this if we use
only video ram it goes perfect i will
show you by a little bit maybe I'm never
nervous okay here's some example of
using different concepts of those
combinations so first of all you see
here we have large data table 302 300
you solve this in kernel of Mathematica
and we have this time here if we go to
the compilation with for example see we
get faster so we can take this into the
account that if we compile this function
we were much much faster of course we
can be we can use also methods with this
table and paralyzation we get a little
bit faster because the dysfunction is
very simple and the compiler choose also
something in in compilation time if we
get a function in Kota like here it's
the same a little bit complicated
because we need take into the account
indexing and so on so we use this we
calculated this in double precision and
this weekend
compute with two different way first of
all we can we can do this in combination
free where we transport the data from
Ram RAM and from from and back if we get
this compilation only one something with
me sorry I think that's the problem okay
good okay if we do not use a transport
the time will be also now reduce it so
the data we live on GPU system so that's
the perfect way not every system
computation concept use this and there
is more more a more complicated systems
like fe m need to transport this data so
that's the problem in fdm method we
don't you we don't need it so we
computed everything on our system so
that's the time as you can see for
example mathematica colonel if we take a
grid size in millions we it's not enough
skull afforded this and if we take the
combination free which we transport the
data between CPU and GPU it's take a lot
of time and this that's the different
and mostly there is the problem to speed
up if you have some function we use GPU
speed up and doesn't happen that's the
problem here if you get only one time to
the cuda to the GPU and then solve the
system in cuda
it's your speed up potential which you
can use so that's most problem of
systems which are custom from for for
commercial use using and so on so that's
most problematic thing okay we go now to
some idea what happens in CUDA I had
implemented this whole system in
homogeneous matrix but I homogeneous
structure but I work now to develop more
complicated shapes it's also not not
problem because we can solve this system
in domain and should it through the CUDA
and then make some computation between
those tables okay now the idea of my my
code is using only veeram put it
everything into the kernel compute with
using shared memory it's very very slow
a very small but very fast you have here
the speed of destroyed memory if we use
it internal in colonel we have pretty
good results to for the speed up here's
some example we use this solver for
bitonic i had wrote some bit onyx sorta
for cuda with a pretty large grid size
for example by 1 million points or
integer double precision points we get
something like one second to sort
everything so it's work pretty well and
also I need to tell about Titan eggs we
have here two different graphic cards
one is my own and the second one was
donated by Nvidia and you can get here
some difference between to those two
because one of them is six gigabyte
veeram and then another is 12 so
the capacity is double okay in my
software I use it or software function
set I use it some of those or all of
those equation we hear PD for motion for
stress Divya toss which are depend from
motion we have stiffness matrix
everything diffusion between cells
temperature diffusion and so a heat
diffusion and so on so basically very
complicated system which is not linear
and must be carefully soft okay because
i work with lab data because I with
large data I've every time problem with
saving of the sets of data so i use
paralia so solving evaluate evaluation
for one trend one process make me this
calculation with cuda and another move
the data to the qadri's how disk I
measured the time between this set and
until the data are move it I break move
to the ram new data set start one more
time the next set of calculations so I
have stand don't have lack of saving the
data in the process so it's very
comfortable you can go to home and
everything will be also saved if we if
you have system complication you can
take the data one more time and return
to your calculations so each data will
be move it to the hard drive okay if we
build some function we have now problem
with compilation
cost so we don't know how large should
be our block block size is very
important and also register size if we
make some optimization on us like here
for example to calculate volume on 1
million elements you can see here's the
function which I used to compile compile
the data i can set here maximum register
which are used / trend and this give me
results with very different speed ups
that means if we compute a compile we
need also to see what kind of graphic
card we use because we have some luck
every time and the pay how large is our
block to how many register we use it's
something like it's depend from our
bandwidth between GPU + + V V rom if we
can optimize it through different block
size we get maximum what is what is for
us in this perfect here if we don't have
using if we don't use this large shared
memory and so on and only generate as
you can see we have we have 700 2 30
cubic grid size so it's very large and
also we can generate some some it's
Kwazii random generator it's also from
from from a little bit change it for
free d generation in i think in data of
mathematical you can find this this
random generator I have little bit
change it for free d in this case in
Mathematica casework this only one D in
3d its work also fine
yeah if we get the optimization about
the size of block we can also speed up
this about fifty percent so it's it's
not so big but even even there if we
have one week one the hits already
something okay what we can do with this
haircut new maybe not new system it's
this idea we can calculate diffusion
this is some system like two different
phases in steel for example we have
austenite which have high a solution of
a carbon and we have ferrite which is
very low solution so by diffusion
calculation we will see a movement of
atoms from ferrite to aus tonight and we
have two different diffusion coefficient
which we can hear also apply this if we
get it we get something like this
results you can see some points it's a
pretty not so good resolution because it
was calculated in for car it was reduced
it to her HD so some points are pixels
are not so pretty well it's you you see
some some problems with calculation if
we want to get some stress calculation
in this system we can do this and I can
show you now this this calculation
results the volume of ferrite is a
little bit higher than austenite so
ferrite want to get out of this and
deform elastic or plastic austenite so
you can see a stress field you
can see some some plastic deformation
where the distress is going down that's
the relaxation of plastic movement of
some some hexahedron okay if we use for
this model for deformation we can use
some some like this model it's a little
bit complicated if you yet it's
something like how much I need to press
to move some some peace or some
hexahedron in this case so we decorate
this in this equation that's give us
non-linearity of equation and here's
some results because this matrix is also
this this pieces was also with Verone oi
a quake 4 annoy method generated with
different texture of grinds in material
you you get a different slip line of
material in this case so with thousand
element you get already pretty cool
results for calculation and also you get
you get information for construction how
much you can deform or how much you can
put it some force on on some pieces okay
now I'm ready with presentation I would
like to show you some some codes and
some movies which we can also gain the
right from this I have a little bit
problem I had really a little bit
problems with generate of some graphics
and movies because everything word was
generating matemática graphic 3d so if i
put
the millions of elements it's become too
air problems but after one week I had
some movies so this is not this here for
this example this computation of this
last one this is sleep effects which you
can also see by deformation in reality
and those effects we observed also in in
our facilities experiment facilities we
can also get a very different grind size
which were here calculated and also we
can see here this it's a little bit slow
because we have many frames here you can
see also the diffusion of change on
concentration between ferrite and
austenite which i already explained this
it's take a little bit time when if it
now you see everything what happens
after this it's really it's really good
simulation because we observed a
microscope the same condition of of
carbon concentration infrared and carbon
concentration in in austenite okay here
simulation of deformation I didn't get
the cross-section this is 12 million
elements which were were simulated
simultaneously on four cards for graphic
cards because the system can make
simulation of four different for
different scenario it's really
interesting to see what's happening here
for example compression test with 12
million elements
and here for example the 1010 size test
of some piece of steel ok now i will
show you some code because the code is a
little bit it's not only text because
this text is interact with my ideas
which i can get ya 18 millimeters so so
we had something like i don't know half
an inch something like that a little bit
smaller or larger so the grinds are
large in this case because this is the
electrical steel with very large vine
sighs ok you can see here very simple
code only text which is then compile
with this function its work each each
function work with double precision so
in this case it's pretty good we
generate here homogeneous matrix
homogeneous grid of the system and this
grid will be deformed before we start
the calculation some sample geometry and
so on so first of all will be well
homogeneous matter homogeneous grid
generated and then this deform to the
numerically to the final start position
final position okay now a little bit
complicated because the CUDA code is
really basic programming I use it
matemática to generate the script of
algorithmic to generate you can see here
for example some eight
eight nodes which I calculate the
vectors of of strain or volume in this
case and then implement this to the real
code the real code which we use it's a
little bit lower in this case here this
is the loading to the shared memory 02
and the real code you can see here ahead
of the code here is a shared memory and
here you get a little bit and here is
the calculation of the volume simply if
we implement this if we use the string
operators we get home we get whole C
code for our computation which we need
so if you change if you want something
to change you can go to the to the
script change something and will be
automatically change in your code later
okay here's the solution computation of
volume for example of hexahedron yeah
here we have also for computation for
stress it's also something like in this
something like this and we get also
after a of strings like here string
drawing replays and so on whole large
script to compiling so thank you very
much for your attention